[Applaudissements]
plaisir n'est plus qu'à une marche de la
montée en fédérale 2 après le succès 25
à 21 du match aller contre pontault
combault les pays hors acp n'ont pas
tremblé longtemps rangé ce dimanche 30
avril une deuxième victoire en deux
matches contre les joueurs de seine et
marne cette fois ci le score a été plus
sévère 28 à 13 avec trois essais
inscrits nota fort en zac à 50 ans près
disait on à caden dominé
territorialement et notamment sur des
séquences de jeu très intéressantes dont
on les a quand même eu des doutes au
long de la partie
ce cas fonctionner c'était un petit peu
comme quand vous match aller quand on a
une belle défense
on sait bien organisé on a beaucoup
travaillé là dessus ces dernier temps en
défense et en mêlée après on a perdu
quelques touchers ce qui est un peu
moins bien fonctionné mais défensivement
défensivement c'était bien donc c'est
peut-être ce qu'a fait la différence
aujourd'hui
une victoire à la saveur particulière
pour l'entraîneur de l'équipe plaisir
oise jean miss celui que l'on surnomme
affectueusement jaloux de l'autre côté
de l'île de france était à la tête de
poteaux combo pendant sept ans non j'ai
pas la tristesse parce que c'est la loi
du sport
on va sans doute alors on va voir une
volière j'ai plus de joie pour premiers
joueurs et les joueurs de plaisir que de
la tristesse pour les joueurs de porto
c'est vrai que il ya une petite note
supplémentaire c'est vrai c'est vrai
mais encore une fois c'est quand même la
compétition qui brille mais il ne faudra
pas non plus avoir de sentiments
prochain tour plaisir fondre à marcq en
baroeul en matches aller-retour avec une
première rencontre dimanche 7 mai à
domicile au stade robert barran en cas
de victoire plaisir trouverez
officiellement la fédérale 2 2 ans après
l'avoir quittée
[Applaudissements]